(orchestra music)
- My eyes are brown.
They're--
- On the smaller side.
- I think my eyes sparkle.
- They're kinda like a poop brown.
- I would say that they were monolids,
which are also called single eyelids,
which means I don't have a crease or fold.
(light orchestra music)
- I know a lot of people
who have used the double
eyelid contraptions.
- I have used eyelid products
to try and correct my monolid.
- The endgame for that, generally,
is for young girls and
boys to get eyelid surgery.
- I guess I wanna see what I
look like with double eyelids.
(light orchestra music)
- Eyelid trainer.
They look like upside down glasses.
- So you're supposed to put them
over your eyes like this?
- I look like a fucking idiot.
Oh my God.
- There we go.
Now I'm beautiful.
- You can't really blink with these on.
- With repeated use, like,
it's supposed to permanently
change your face,
but I don't really believe it.
I don't think the face is that malleable.
- You know what?
I would use this product
if it gave me six-pack abs.
(light orchestra music)
- Eye Charm eyelid tape.
- If I don't go blind,
this will be a success.
- You somehow put the little white part
onto the green stick,
and then just shove it in your eye.
- Just poke at it until
you get the right shape?
This is like, this is
like "A Clockwork Orange."
- Hope that's where it goes.
If I had double eyelids,
maybe I'd be too beautiful for the world.
- Look at that shit, look
at that, look at that!
Oh fuck, it created a line.
- Fold the skin over, ah!
Um, yeah, so it,
it stuck, but I look crazy.
- It's another version of me
that I don't think is
necessarily better looking.
I think, for me, it's just strange.
(light orchestra music)
- Glue?
You want me to put glue on my eye?
If this gets in my eye, will I go blind?
- [Voiceover] No.
- Alright, let's do it.
- This is the product that
I used in high school,
and if I remember correctly,
I needed to use, like, a lot of glue.
- This some horror movie shit right here.
- It's so much easier to just
love what your mama gave you.
- Oh no, that's terrifying.
- [Voiceover] Oh shit.
- This is it, it stuck.
That took like two seconds.
- You know what, what a world we live in,
where you can alter the shape of your face
how ever you want to.
- As soon as I put it on, I'm just like,
"Oh yeah, like, I
remember why I used that."
And it's like, I don't think anyone else
would notice the difference
in my face, except for me.
(light violin music)
- This freaked me out.
This really freaked me out.
Cause I don't even recognize
the person I'm looking at in this mirror.
- I feel like I'm more
accepting of my monolids,
because this just made me realize
how much I don't care about
having double eyelids.
- I started using these
products when I was younger,
and I was a lot more insecure.
And now that I'm an adult,
I think I should probably be
at this place where it's like,
"Oh yeah, like, I'm totally cool,
and I don't feel insecure
about my eyes anymore."
And it's like, obviously
that's not totally true.
- I'm wondering if it
would've been worth, like,
getting the double eyelid
surgery when I was younger.
And I don't think so, cause I
like my eyes the way they are.
- For those who are
struggling with their looks,
just remember that there is
a lot of people out there
who don't share the opinion
that you have to have a double
eyelid to look beautiful.
(light orchestra music)